bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag la
pandémie liée aux qu'ovide 19 aura
marqué l'année 2020 nous reviendrons sur
les mesures prises pour y faire face à
saint quentin en yvelines
malgré tout d'autres chantiers ont été
avancés ou se sont poursuivies notamment
dans le domaine de l'emploi et des
apprentissages mais aussi dans le
secteur de l'agriculture et de
l'écologie enfin nous ferons un point
sur les chantiers en cours pour la
mobilité
on fait le point sur l'année 2020 c'est
parti
[Musique]
2020 année de la crise sanitaire dès le
1er confinement du 16 mars
des mesures ont été appliquées pour
soutenir les populations
l'institut de promotion de la santé a
conservé un accueil téléphonique
généralistes pour informer les saint
quentinois sur la crise sanitaire et
ainsi désengorger les services
hospitaliers masqué visière et ont été
distribués pour les professionnels de
santé
li ps a aussi gardé un lien avec les
pensionnaires des ehpad et un lien
envers les plus jeunes pour les tests
deux centres ont été mises en place
[Musique]
côté économies le territoire à apporter
un soutien actif en direction des
entreprises
l'agglomération a effectivement lancé un
plan de reprise de relance de 2 millions
d'euros
[Musique]
avec plusieurs leviers d'abord nous
avons exonérés de loyer redevance tout
ce qui pouvait dépendre de nos bâtiments
publics
et puis saint quentin a largement
participé au déploiement de son
résilience un qui a été lancé par la
région et donc saint quentin a apporté
également une somme une somme non
négligeable pour aider
je dirais aux déploiements des prêts
guide de relance explicatif soutien
téléphonique aide aux créateurs de
projets au sein de l'incubateur ski tube
testing au vélodrome pour les salariés
en septembre dernier l'agglomération
avait mis en place trois jours de
testing à la demande des entreprises
3000 salariés étaient venus se faire
dépister
[Musique]
l'agglomération a aussi maintenu les
rendez vous phares comme le ski deux
essais en piste en ciel
autre secteur cruellement d'impact et
celui du commerce d'agglomération a créé
une plateforme facebook dédiée aux
commerçants et aux agriculteurs c'est le
site sky soutient ces commerçants y
avait vraiment une montée des commandes
au fur et à mesure c était vraiment un
énorme coup d'accélérateur
plus récemment a été créé la boutique en
ligne chopine ski une marketplace
impulsée par l'agglomération et les
douze communes saint-quentinoise
toujours en direction des commerces et
des agriculteurs la culture c'est aussi
réinventer le réseau des médiathèques
est passé en mode drive sur le principe
du click and collect l'accès gratuit à
engendrer une hausse des consultations
les heures du conte étant plus
accessible pendant le confinement
ce 6 août étaient proposés en ligne en
juillet la programmation partir en livre
s'est effectuée par le biais d'ateliers
en ligne également la commanderie elle a
proposé des séances de cinéma en plein
air
[Musique]
autre préoccupation l'emploi et la
formation
certains grands rendez-vous ont pu se
tenir avant le confinement de mars
d'autres actions ont ensuite été impulsé
pour soutenir l'insertion
professionnelle
qui dit entreprises des emplois le 27
février 2020 avant le confinement 3000
visiteurs s'étaient rendus au vélodrome
pour le troisième ce qui emploie en pis
et vêtements l'événement phare on a près
de 1000 entreprises présentes on a près
3000 offres d'emploi on a un public très
large 2021 l'opération devrait être
maintenue au vélodrome probablement au
printemps
chaque commune préparera l'événement en
amont afin que postulants et entreprises
soit fin prêt
le nombre des demandeurs d'emploi sur
saint quentin en yvelines a augmenté de
plus de 25% avec la crise sanitaire déjà
des plans sociaux se dessine
certains secteurs sont aussi en
souffrance le tourisme la restauration
l'événementiel d'autres recrutent
le numérique de btp et services à la
personne et le secteur de la santé le
territoire opère entre soutien des
secteurs en difficulté et orientation
des salariés vers les secteurs en
tension en 2020 des rendez-vous ont été
impulsés pour l'emploi des jeunes
un summer cup aux promos paul en juillet
sur les métiers du numérique un hidjab
dating en octobre entre postulants et
entreprises le plan un jeune une
solution a été mise en place pour
faciliter l'entrée dans la vie
professionnelle sans mes missions de
service civique proposé accompagnement
de deux cent mille jeunes vers les
métiers d'avenir 300000 parcours
d'insertion sur mesure pour les jeunes
éloignés de l'emploi
l'agglomération soutient aussi les
filières de l'alternance il exploite
dispositif pour joue dit les apprentis
pour les jeunes sur les baisses de
charges donc à nous l'agglomération de
les relayer auprès des entreprises et
pour initier au numérique dès le plus
jeune âge un fonds de concours dédié de
plus de 7 millions d'euros a vu le jour
le plan de déploiement du numérique
scolaire concerne 28 mille élèves de 204
écoles maternelles et élémentaires
en parallèle le campus numérique créé en
2010 est poursuit son développement de
nouvelles cessions se sont ouvertes en
2020 développement multi média et
marketing digital internet des objets
réseaux et sécurité
autre point pour la formation made in
saint quentin l'excellence de
l'université paris saclay classé au 14e
rang mondial du classement de shanghai
la crise sanitaire a permis d'accélérer
certains chantiers déjà en cours les
saint quentinois se sont tournés vers
les circuits courts et ont découvert des
agriculteurs au plus près de chez eux
la préservation de la nature est aussi
devenue une priorité
[Musique]
côté agriculture on a continué de mettre
en place le plan de développement qui
avait été votée la dépasser
[Musique]
un plan de développement qui est sur
plusieurs objectifs
un objectif de pérennisation de
l'agriculture existantes de sa
diversification et de son développement
et puis aussi un développement de la
diffusion pour l'alimentation locale
c'est-à-dire du développement des
circuits courts le territoire a
travaillé sur le foncier pour que les
agriculteurs conserve un accès à la
terre les baux précaires sont ainsi
devenus des baux ruraux
des subventions ont été allouées aux
agriculteurs pour les aider à
diversifier les cultures soutient aussi
pour l'ouverture de magasins fermiers le
premier confinement a permis de faire se
rencontrer aviculteurs locaux et
consommateurs huile de colza sur manu
les ânes ou viande amour pas fruits à
villepreux il y a des une
diversification aujourd'hui qui est
impressionnante et qu'on trouve soit
dans des magasins locaux soit dans les
amap qui sont aussi fortement développée
sur sur saint quentin en yvelines ou
bien sûr des des épiceries participative
peut-être que beaucoup de gens
n'imaginaient pas que sur saint quentin
en yvelines directement et justes aux
abords on avait la capacité finale ronde
se nourrir à magny les hameaux ou à la
ferme but loyer est né un projet de
ferme école graines d'avenir production
locale et formation de jeunes à
l'agriculture et à la diffusion des
produits locaux la première rentrée est
prévue pour octobre 2021
un projet qui allie formation et emploi
ou non délocalisables
consommez local mais aussi retrouver la
biodiversité dans la ville pour faire
face au réchauffement climatique c'est
aussi le défi de saint quentin en
yvelines sur les espaces verts c'est une
poursuite cette année de la gestion
différenciée des coupes différentes et
un entretien différent qui permet de
redonner de la vie à la nature de
laisser pousser la nature tout
simplement
il y a aussi la gestion des arbres qui
est importante on a une charte de
l'arbre qu'on remet en route pour
pouvoir expliquer cette importance qui
lie à avoir des arbres dans notre dans
notre communauté d'agglomération des
espèces locales sont replantés qui
nécessite moins de ressources en eau
pour répondre aux canicules qui
reviennent désormais chaque été
développement d'éco pâturages de
l'agriculture urbaine grâce à la
plantation d'arbres fruitiers et
installation de cabanes à oiseaux pour
accueillir les espèces et de ruches pour
davantage de nature dans la cité
d'autres innovations écologiques ont été
impulsés une plateforme solaire de
dépollution sur le bassin de val fleuri
à coignières et la mise en place d'un
éclairage autonoma voisins le bretonneux
[Musique]
côté flotte automobile le club climat
énergie de saint quentin en yvelines a
lancé en septembre 2020 le premier
service d'autopartage interentreprises
des yvelines l'opération ski share
permet de mutualiser les véhicules et de
limiter les émissions de polluants en
choisissant des voitures plus propres
hybrides ou électriques
[Musique]
autre priorité la réduction des déchets
le plan local de prévention des déchets
ménagers et assimilés est en cours
d'élaboration
harmonisation des collectes sur les
douze communes développement de
compostage une collecte des encombrants
réaménagé et plus de services et de
déchets acceptés dans les déchetteries
dernier axe fort les transports de
nombreuses transformations étaient mise
en oeuvre dans les pôle gare ces
dernières années et se sont poursuivies
en 2020 bus piste cyclable trottinettes
électriques ont fait tour de la mobilité
[Musique]
c'est
aujourd'hui il ya beau plusieurs projets
qui seront portés par l'agglomération de
saint quentin et notamment des projets
qui étaient déjà dans les tuyaux et des
nouveaux projets nouveaux projets je
pense notamment au déploiement des
trottinettes électriques qui va être
important il va falloir qu'on avance sur
les différents contrats et les pôles
l'épaule de gare et mobilité à commencer
par celle de montigny le bretonneux 70
mille voyageurs et transitent chaque
jour elle sera le passage obligé de bien
plus de visiteurs pour les géo 2024
puisque certaines disciplines se
tiendront sur saint quentin en yvelines
depuis octobre dernier la gare a
commencé sa mue travaux de mise en
accessibilité pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite modernisation des excès
mais pas seulement
c'est à bord et le centre ville sont en
pleine réhabilitation plus accueillant
moins minéral avec plus d espace pour
les piétons les cyclistes et les
terrasses de café direction à verrières
depuis deux ans la gare et ses environs
ont été transformés mise en oeuvre du
transport collectif en site propre via
le doublement du pont guy schuller
réalisation des aménagements aux abords
une nouvelle phase de travaux a démarré
en novembre avec la réalisation de la
voie d'accès au futur parking relais de
la gare
sur le parvis de la gare villepreux et
clayes-sous-bois les travaux ont été
impulsés en mars avec un parking agrandi
végétalisée comportant des bancs publics
davantage de places réservées aux
piétons et un accès plus facile à la
circulation des transports en commun qui
dit transports en commun du réseau de
bus celui ci a été renforcée découvre
son été augmenté un bus articulé a été
mise à la disposition des élèves du
lycée de villa roi d'autres livres ou vu
leur parcours étant dû modifier
huit nouvelles lignes sont accessibles
aux personnes à mobilité réduite depuis
septembre
[Musique]
côté circulation douce de nouvelles
pistes cyclables à montigny le
bretonneux trappe
aiguillon cours viennent enrichir les
420 kilomètres d'itinéraire cyclable
existant un projet de piste cyclable au
nord de l'île de loisirs est également
engagée forte de ses nombreuses pistes
vélo l'agglomération a lancé un appel à
candidatures pour son projet de
trottinettes électriques une nouvelle
mobilité pour 2021
[Musique]
vous savez tout sur 2020 place à 2021 a
pas bientôt ciao
[Musique]